i think it's really easy to lose focus
when you're an entrepreneur like just so
many projects going on
so many thinking going on in your head
so
it has been very important to me to
clarify
my prioritization the thoughts and
just keep moving like with those focuses
[Music]
i'm jian zhong ceo of many me many me is
the designer manicure marketplace
providing custom fit ready-to-wear
manicures
i love getting manicures but i had no
time to
go to nail salon when i had to like work
every day so i wanted to create a
solution
that busy woman can enjoy
as an immigrant founder like with a
non-permanent residency status
and with all those kobe 19 added to this
picture
i'm currently living in a country where
i'm not
certain whether or not i can stay
it's a very scary thing totally out of
my control
i think the way it does help me is that
it really drives me to excellence
[Music]
american dream to me is no matter
how you look what you sound like where
you came from
hard work is rewarded excellence
honesty is rewarded
you